parce que maintenant car je dois faire
les courses frère c'est même une vraie
d'arca je me disais ça la dernière fois
tu vas pas faire les courses dont j'ai
fait vous faites les courses ou non mais
ça fait un jour je vous dis en vérité un
jour je suis allée acheter du chocolat
soit
[Applaudissements]
et j'arrive à la caisse avis frère
maintenant tu arrives à la caisse et
frère l'école mais parce qu'ils
repartent comme ça mais oui parce que
c'est la plus d'oseille mon frère il
faut que tu achètes les centres n'ont
écouté le sac c'est un euro gelly frère
il n'y a pas un petit 4 centimes
ils prennent un cabas mon frère je pense
que ça tu es là mais là la maison frère
je veux te dire que tu impressionne tout
le monde freire sont recyclés règle avec
ce sac à la maison mon frère on te dit
tu as et qui se la cote là bas son
sackboy fond des sacs comme tu chantes
chocolat matin la pression du sang des
trucs de nous tous les garder chez soi
et les ramener l'événement pour chaque
fois mais c'est pas comme ça mais la
raison mais hélas la 150 ans mon frère
abel arrive elle arrive à base de cabas
comme quoi les mecs je peux pas soit les
terres le marché une tâche déjà sans
hormones et le cam qui te dit je vais
faire le marché je sais que ça y est il
a passé un cap dans sa muse et que ça y
est il est passé là l'horloge biologique
à tapis sur un marché non pas du tout
parce que toi t'es fait n'est en soi pas
messieurs les les jeunes qui nous
regardent vous voyez votre homme quand
elle part avec le caddie comme un saint
williams a remarqué qu'après mon frère
est tout autant quand elle rentre des
ducs de durs des courses mon frère est
d'abord il ya le cadet qui tape un peu
contre la taupe
ça c'est ma femme qui rentrait ya des
poireaux qui dépasse 7 mai des auberges
et des trucs qu'on ment jamais mon frère
on mange que des petits mots et
d'harrison brouillon marcher moi je
revois à l'idée vient qu'avec des trucs
bouffard qu'on montre jamais el mada
joël masson était un légume mon frère je
croyais que c'était un le prénom d'une
amie elle elle m'a dit j'ai ramené des
salsifis des sentiers de dollarama
décidé mais on va légèrement sa ville
centre
elle m'a dit vous faire des boulettes ha
oui ça va tu vas faire marcher un peu
les dimanches et fêtes mais acheta gras
sera mérité mieux bonjour je découpe les
coupons promo qu'elle n'en ait pu
attirer les boîtes aux lettres non du
coup quand je les prends ce que je fais
j'ai déménagé dont je peux le dire
j'ouvrais les boîtes aux lettres des
voisins de table dans mon immeuble à me
faire avec le voisinage une phalange
suis là et donc je prends les coupons
des autres mais énorme sur une bonne
main sur ben aboud sur du lait c'est 15
centimes jusqu'à la fin situe alors
c'est chiant pour les gens derrière ça
prend un petit peu de temps a bien sûr
mais avec tous les coupons battu gagne
bien 5 6 euros à raison et toi tu fais
tu fais ce que tu veux de marché chez
toi bien sûr j l'écho fait le marché
ouais général on ya plus de caissière
mal an tu tu passes mal alors si huawei
cartons 6 10 mais oui tu passes toi même
tes produits et c'est pas mieux la
caissière et maintenant tu payes
directement toi avec la carte way a mais
toi frère tu dois rester huit heures en
fait
l'effet des week-ends chez carrefour
market
je suis pas là ce week end phare
week-end-là carrefour market
j'ai deux trois bouteilles achetées
quand matin il faut dire prisunic
monoprix bien entendu chez auchan
carrefour intermarché et bien sûr les
mousquetaires les chiens à exister
prisunic oui si ça doit exister bien
bien au coeur des gens